benjamin grange ce sont des sujets qui
passionnent les internautes cette ce
référendum catalan alors au risque de
vous décevoir
assez peu en fait simplement parce que
quand on regarde la manière dont on en
parle
et d'ailleurs même les conséquences que
ce référendum pourrait avoir sur
l'europe
eh bien on trouve pas grand chose est
d'ailleurs associé à barcelone on va
surtout parler du barça on va surtout
parler du football ou des derniers
transferts mais relativement peu de ce
référendum
donc est ce que c'est un sujet très
parisien est ce que finalement c'est un
sujet qui reste comment dire encore un
peu intellectuel sur les réseaux sociaux
où d'habitude on a une caisse de
résonance souvent dans l'ombre de
crainte d'un certain nombre de peurs là
aujourd'hui on en trouve des traces très
très faible